in this video I'm going to multiply 87
times 63 but I'm not going to do it just
by using some some process by just
showing you some steps instead we're
just going to use the distributive
property to actually try to calculate
this thing so first what I'm going to do
let me rewrite 87 let me rewrite so this
is the same thing as 87 but instead of
writing 63 like that I'm going to write
63 as 60 60 plus 360 plus 3 now what is
this going to be equal to well 87 times
60 plus 3 that's going to be the same
thing as let me actually copy and paste
this so this is going to be the same
thing as so it's going to be 87 times 60
87 times 60 Plus 87 plus 87 times 3 plus
87 times 3 you could say that we've just
distributed we have just distributed the
87 we're multiplying 87 times 60 Plus 3
that's 87 times 60 Plus 87 times 3 I
could put parentheses here to make it a
little bit clearer well fair enough but
then how do you calculate what this is
well now we can rewrite 87 as 80 plus 7
so let's rewrite that so this is the
same thing actually let me write it this
way I can swap them around so this is
the same thing as 60 times 87 but I'll
write that as 60 60 times 80 plus 7 like
this 80 plus 7 plus plus 3 times 80 plus
7 or 3 times 87 let me write let me just
copy and paste that so I don't have to
keep switching colors plus 3 times 80
plus 7 so copy and then let me paste it
and then
you have it just like that so all I did
just to be clear all of what you see
right over here 87 87 times 60 well
that's the same thing as 60 times 87
which is the same thing as 60 times 80
plus 7 all that you see are 87 times 3
that's the same thing as 3 times 87
which is the same thing as 3 times 80
plus 7 that's just that over here but
look we can distribute again we can
distribute the 60 times sine times 80
plus 7 so this is going to be 60 I'm
going to do that same color color
changing is hard this is 60 times 80
times 80 plus 60 plus 60 times 7 times
times 7 plus plus 3 times 80 plus 3
times 80 plus 3 times 7 so plus plus 3
times 3 times actually let me do it 3
times 7 right over here so notice what
we really did is we thought about what
each of these digits represent 8
represents 87 represents 7 6 represents
60 because it's in the tens place the 8
was in the tens place as well this 3 is
in the ones way so it's just 3 and we
just multiplied them all together we
multiplied the 80 times the 60 we
multiply the 80 times the 3 we multiply
the 7 times the 60 right over here we
multiply the 7 times the 3 and then we
add them all up together and this will
actually give us our product so for
example this right over here 6 times 8
is 48 but this isn't 6 eighths this is
60 80s so this is going to be 4,800
we've got 2 zeros right over here so 48
followed by the 2 zeros this right over
here 60 times 7 is 4420 6 times 7 is 42
there's going to be ten times as much
because this is a 60 and then 3 times 80
well same logic 3 times 8 is 20
four so this is going to be 240 and then
finally 3 times 7 is 21 and then to get
the product we can add these two
together and you might be saying a Sal I
know faster ways of doing this but the
whole reason I'm doing this is to show
you that that fast way you knew how to
do it it's just it's not some magical
formula or some magical process you're
doing it just comes out of really
distributive property and hopefully a
little bit of common sense so what is
this going to be equal to well we could
add them all up 4,800 plus 420 + 240 +
21 where you get a 1 here let's see 20
plus 40 plus 20 is 80
let's see 800 plus 400 is 1200 plus 2
more 200 more is 1400 or 1400 and so you
get five thousand four hundred and
eighty one it's equal to five thousand
four hundred and eighty one and you
might say gee you know this was this was
a bit of a pain to have to do the
distributive property over and over
again is there a simpler way to maybe
visualize this and there is you could
actually write this as a grid so we
could say we're multiplying eighty seven
times 63 we can write it like this we
could say it's 80 plus seven eighty plus
seven times 60 60 plus three plus three
and then you can set up a grid like this
so let me set up a little box here it's
two digits by two digits so it's going
to be a 2x2 grid two rows and two
columns and then you just have to
calculate well what 60 times 80 well we
already calculated that that's 4,800
what is 60 times seven well that's going
to be 400 400 and 220 what is three
times 80 we already calculated that that
is 240 I don't do that same color 240
and finally what is 3 times 721 you add
them all together you get five thousand
four hundred and eighty-one and I
encourage you to now just do this this
the same multiplication problem the same
87 times 63 the way that you might have
traditionally learned it and
see and look at the different steps and
why they are making sense and why at the
end of the day you really are doing the
same thing that you just did in this
video you're just doing in a different
way and the whole point of this whole
exercise this whole video is so that you
really get the understand so you're not
just blindly doing some type of steps to
find the product of two numbers but you
can actually understand why those steps
work and how those numbers relate to
each other